[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is always waffling and complaining
here's a court killer
[Music]
five million
suspended from the
hello hello family again and welcome to
the OU degrees going on of our gigabits
owns the watched we're tonight we're
gonna be watching game massan's season 5
which may be my favorite has some of my
favorite episodes in its night so we're
excited to dive in we're gonna watch the
episodes with you and then we're gonna
answer some questions between them oh
I'm Craig we're also going to have a
clip of a deleted scene from the season
at the end so stay tuned for that
because it's pretty good don't you agree
Adam it's not really a deleted scene
it's a scene we couldn't use because the
the playoffs didn't work out that way
but I think we were gonna write we're
gonna do play out sort the other way so
do you want to I guess one thing we'll
answer right before we start is we
always get the question of why is game
of zones ending and a lot of people
think blue chip or canceled the show
that's not the case Bleacher Report's
did not cancel the show it's more that
Craig and I have done seven seasons of
this now and it's near and dear to our
heart but it's we've made every medieval
basketball joke we can make for right
now and we want to try some new things
creatively but you know who knows maybe
in the future we can we can come back
and and and and pick it up again one
other thing I want to add is that we're
gonna be talking over the episodes so if
that bugs you you are free to watch the
episodes on YouTube in their natural
habitat but we're gonna be annoying and
talking over all these episodes so just
be prepared for that
yes so this next episode or this first
step so we're going to show you is
called Kairos farewell I believe or at
least that's the working title that were
using it's what one youtuber described
as the best and deepest game of zones
ever made fora
that's a quote straight from YouTube
comments section and I think we should
just roll table if there's anything else
Adam that this this came out all-star
weekend of whatever season this was out
what do you guys something
but the 70th NBA season oh there's our
disclaimer that we always put at the
beginning yeah none of this any real
people even though people may look like
real NBA players none of them are
they're all just made-up characters yeah
lots of looking trick a lot of
references here there's a little keV
here and this is a little portrait that
Richard Jefferson and Channing Tatum and
I checked around and buy gum yeah like
there's not a set of magic mic that so
yeah the Cavs just lost the Warriors big
news this summer free agency was was
well I guess it was Kevin Durant
that's know that was the year before
sorry this one was this was the Kyrie
going to the old Boston Celtics yeah and
this is the bronze foot statue but
they're little over dance they go by
like this oh yeah that's because we
didn't want to draw them sideways so we
just had them walk like shot side
shuffle differences those are the
henchmen is that what better much the
same many men's are writing only to
obscure a deeper desire to mellow on his
way to Oklahoma City chapter comes to a
close we gave Paul George a golden leg
after his leg injury like Jaime
Lannister's holdin hands I may find that
I was
taken that I needed you all alone and
this is a background that we would use
later for Lorraine stables castle
enjoyment and so I've set sail for the
edge of the world but if I find that
this world is indeed round and maybe one
day my journey will lead me back to you
in my stead awaits another remember the
Arthur me quite a bit of its business to
you all right yeah it's been prompted
yeah I was popularly it's hard to harden
remember meanings these days so many
yeah they got Isaiah Connor and I'm not
to be a big deal yeah so women tell you
a little anecdote about this party
having dirt doesn't bode well for us
getting out to say we had to deal with
the back of Kevon trading right before
the separate them out
LeBron goes full cersei here
he was once Jamie then he became never
go for money and he went full Cersei
he's a chapter there real quick
so so the thing with that episode at the
end there was that that was coming out
of the all-star break and I believe it
was right before that episode was about
to come out that like LeBron traded like
half that team and we were like oh man
what do we it was like literally it
sorry it was like it was like a seven
days maybe 10 days ahead of this episode
coming out and it was like the worst
thing that could possibly happen to an
animated show that's based on live like
real news anyway you want to tell the
story but basically we decided the best
thing to do was to just blow it up with
a whoa mom and and do a and use spoof
that scene with Cersei where spoiler
alert if you haven't see where she blows
some stuff up so and it turned out to be
it's not be good so we were happy with
it and actually looks really good that's
me i flex and everything we got pretty
lucky that you know we had that kind of
ace up our sleeve of when in doubt just
blow everything up you know because that
was a gift that he blew it up so I was
or something else for this one driven
the the IT baby story yeah we were gonna
do it that like the explosion was so big
that like IT flew all the way this all
the way to LA and landed on the doorstep
of Magic Johnson and he was less all
like IT is like a little baby on his
doorstep and he picked him up like a UH
like a baby he was going to bring into
his a humble Lakers house but uh so his
next episode a lot of you may not have
seen it because it was actually a half
of it the this net scene was only on the
app it was APICS cluesive and it was
split up it was initially going to be
part of one big episode but we decided
half of it to be an app exclusive and
now we're putting it back together you
can see if you watch the full string out
it's it's attached to sewed one but
we'll go ahead and listen do you want to
say Craig and play this episode that you
know it's doing
bring out your bike is the noid of crabs
you should have been here all along
there you go for your troubles not me
things no the guy on the horse or things
oh boy that contracts a doozy Freight
I'm gonna need a couple draft picks to
take him on fine this is based on a
Monty Python steamed bring out your dead
yeah you should watch that and then
watch this scene Brian lawn colors
before his colors got really yeah so
you're just gonna send me off to
Brooklyn just like his collar so notice
look Julian I've tried ever since the
train to pin a new innovation the season
what some archers to spice the field it
was a the other thing you get out of bed
for but for me yeah yeah yeah which are
GM can you please take this guy
describes are killing me I'll throw in a
second route they'll melt off renders
their turn he's good on day and has 18
business
fun fact trevor booker does have a teen
business might even have a 19 or 20 now
for all I know
so we rise from the depths of the nets
and their problems to the highest of the
highs this given house Golden State ah
this portrait or this painting I don't
even know what to call the the Sistine
Chapel parody and one of my favorite
pieces of are eating the rat fell on the
JaVale McGee I'm off his numbers from
last year you could make the case he's
become one of the best shooters in the
realm you can never have too much
shooting Steph clay your thoughts oh
yeah oh yeah I think it's unsafe a bit
shaky this was the year ever klay
Thompson talking about scaffolding on
the local news and just came looks like
a trip down memory lane
on ourselves with Thank You Patrick know
if you hear of anything
swaggy has his moments but all too often
my be they said the same of Javel but
I'd say he's worked out quite nicely
I just really is like we are doing just
two types of service of documenting all
the memes Ian yes Patrick cartoon form
these pervs generation they say you
might make the sixes active roster oh ok
Patrick maybe just notify us if any big
names change houses understood right
right big names gorgeous so there's an
interesting tidbit about this know by
the way but it's a big name who love
famous I don't know
so Vince Carter feeling about him like
he got seriously injured Macaulay
right around the time a week before this
came out like fell on his tailbone
falling over Vince Carter and we were
really worried that like can't talk
doesn't Carter and mention that we
didn't paralyze when we saw that he was
really scary but turned out he was fine
so we were able to leave the joke in
there I think we even added a little
thing that home now is role you may be
right
this is not the swaggy P of you he's
known his uncle swaggy now all right
green can do that catch on that a
contract I don't think so but I'm not
the right person to ask right I'm not
everyone yes sir Chris Paul has been
traded to house Rockets but wait there's
more Jimmy Butler Steph Curry knowing
the bond his arrow the way he knows on
mouth guard we figured in medieval times
he would have that same habit but hole
in the West would be again in a tricked
a medieval object only bring us news
that actually affects our chances the
scene was actually I found this thing
kind of like not my favorite I was I
thought it was you know something kind
of warming my positives in there so
maybe we should take some questions what
do you think Adam okay let's do a couple
questions will let's start with a
phoenix rising 77077 says who does
kairi's voice I do kairi's voice he is
one of a few characters like Chris Paul
who has a bit of a tyrion voice but
Chris Paul's voice is more of a tyrion
lowered syrian like this and Kyrie has a
bit more of us more of a snobbish Tyrion
the cat no I don't think so no I'm curry
it's no baby
actually he evolved to be a bit snobby
er as his story like evolved in his
character and is like he became a little
bit more of an NBA villain you got a
little bit snobby or in our voice Craig
you have a question you an answer we
have a request from Daniel
boa he says don't talk over the deleted
scene please we will not we got don't
worry we're gonna expect the deleted
scene we're gonna respect it with with
with silence I promise and then one more
question here which is why were you so
mean to the Nets and how are you going
to redeem with KD and Kyrie
so we're mean to the nest I think yeah I
mean actually portrayed Sean marks as
like an intelligent GM who was you know
making doing strategic moves and you
know taking him out of the bottom yeah
and also you know mean to me is being
ignored we ignore teams you can consider
that mean and your team gets in there
you know that's that's that's us showing
respect and then as far as KD and Kyrie
you'll have to have to wait and see for
this season all right let's let's jump
into one of our favorite episodes the
Sun King yeah this is based on these
Stannis and Renly Alliance team if you
didn't know that from Game of Thrones
and watch that syllabus they've
entrusted me as emissary now what is
this trade thread no we made a Devin
Booker emissary because we didn't wanna
have Lord Sarver as the link together we
just wanna be I've gotta be more
interesting to be devin booker eggs
Devin Booker by the way based on Renly
Baratheon that's where he's well what if
I told you you could digress yeah Steph
Curry and part of this was because
there's one of the things about Game of
Thrones is that there's a ton of
alliances and like we could you can't
really do alliances because they never
happen in real basketball how so this
was our attempt at trying to we've taken
come close early
also Big C Achilles yeah Craig's like a
fiery Crescent antler is one of my
locally favorite characters there they
made him a guy he just chimed in on
artistic points of yeah he's like a
freshman in a painting class or
something dragon another scene with a
lot of how many guys okay
similar the person yeah basically and
the rule of thumb if you weren't here
yesterday is that when we run out of
heads we can make for scene because we
only have a certain amount of time and
resources you start putting helmets on
guys
so I always feel bad for the guys don't
make the heads the Koufos made the just
like yes when we join forces in cement
oh you mean in Phoenicia Oh for heaven's
sakes we just built a state-of-the-art
castle isn't Sacramento bit smooth just
to go to video what it's hundred twenty
degrees every day it's cooler nights and
besides do you expect us to abandon a
city with such a rich basketball history
well clearly you are not familiar with
the rich history of house Kings Lord
commands bloody one of the Miss
characters oh come on they don't even
compare to D'Antoni this seems time at
this point supposed evolved into like
any argument agreed like in some random
right who's better keep the best
response team of that era like the
Phoenix Suns versus like the
the Chris Webber white chocolate maybe
we are bunch of balls oh yeah forces are
hard to walk
[Applause]
well then steel probably won't make the
playoff we got better at that as the
seasons went on well what are you
looking to be fair I couldn't even make
it back you see a bunch of guys we stink
TJ Warren imagine tweeting us after this
episode I guess my point is oh I don't
know yeah yeah he said something like
some tweet up ingria so that's one thing
I want to say about this episode is that
originally the ending was going to we
couldn't figure how to end the scene and
arisen what we're gonna do was have a
dragon bender be a dragon bender and he
was actually we're gonna have survived
like Chris boss or a dragon come by and
then he was gonna bend it and they're
gonna realize that that was his true
value is that he could bend the dragon
but didn't make the Eric Bledsoe made
that tweet and then we realized that was
the ending to go with yeah yeah but yeah
so this next scene unless you want to
take oh yeah let's take some questions
next scene is a box which is by a single
question first of all ooh
fat Kid Rock says Adam where the onions
worth it
normally yes not in this case this this
thing would not stop bleeding so that
was I was scary actually like I was
slightly concerned at one point but then
it was fine but if I'm doing this
episode it's because it's because I ran
out blood we sow onions or the boo boo
I don't know but I was crying so let's
see Wes Cole says how did you add that
Vince part so quit that quick and
actually the reason we were able to add
that Vince Carter part quickly is that
he already made that jokes he was
already talking about Vince Carter that
was why I was so weirdly coincidental
when the injury happened because of
Vince Carter and so all we did was
quickly add I think a line or something
I prayed exactly what it was but
something to acknowledge like you know
how scary he is I don't have a good
feeling about him or something like that
Craig any questions that are catching
your your eye uh Christopher Torres says
so you guys just hate the Nuggets lol no
we actually don't um we've been trying
really hard to get the Nuggets into game
of zones and we just keep the key being
like unfortunate things that happen that
like prevent it we had a whole scene
that was supposed to be in episode 6
that was like one of my favorite scenes
we've ever written and then it became
kind of obsolete
so yeah the idea there I'll quickly sum
up that scene which was the idea there
was that when LeBron was going into free
agency if they would have lost in the
first round that year I think they were
down they were down to someone I came
rember who was in the first year this
last year at Cleveland and we had
prepped this idea that he would go into
free agency and he would walk towards
the Nuggets and you get to see the whole
world of Denver and the mountain people
there and they have nuggets of
everything they have chicken nuggets
they're harvesting and weed nuggets
they're harvesting and and gold nuggets
and it's like this happy little world
and then like the Brawn walks up and he
walks up like the hound in that scene
where there's all those happy little
people or whatever his hairs all know
now yeah yeah he's like he's got like a
full like Hound style like comb-over
type situation LeBron and just like any
walk through that and then like they're
like oh my god he's actually coming here
and they tried it and also in their
happy world where they were happy and
the a/c is turned upside down and they
all start like throwing each other off
cliffs and mountains to try and make cap
space for LeBron but then he just keeps
walking right past them and continues on
to LA so it was something like that but
it just never panned out that way so
apologize to
two Nuggets fans but you can check out
yoke it should be in a card at the end
of one of the episodes and maybe he'll
appear in this next season you have to
watch it Thursday at noon all right why
don't we dig into the next episode which
is one of my favorites all-time yes
[Music]
why is it called the mill of Waukee
because sometimes we just do things we
don't need to do Ferguson and Milton
calling him Milwaukee's one of them this
is our horror intro to swim now this is
for all intensive purposes this is Yanis
is real debut he appeared for a second
in this is our first chance to really
show him yeah this is really about that
the fatlings sees your thoughts we don't
know what to foul in the last two
minutes of battle okay I mean even
though have tonight I've given up on you
11 of them it a deep dive into
everything they're saying about Jason
Kidd and on reddit to get all the
information on this listen to some
podcasts thought this of Bucs films I
could stop subtle joke there about Yanis
never been trying alcohol before I love
egg smoothies because at the end of the
day I must be true to who I am in here
and in here I am an [ __ ]
I'd like that a Meredith [ __ ] gave no
clue what I'm doing with her little bird
Jason cave a little name tags in those
pajamas you've allowed me to do for you
so that's because like I actually
thought that I'm like wait sorry
and I'm like I'm gonna write that in
Philly other people might forget that
and also because this is a reference to
any drop soda to call the timeout but
him calling himself an [ __ ] there's
probably my favorite game is in joke of
all time
I think in here I am an [ __ ]
a big dog so this is based on the Crips
and Robin from under Winterfell [ __ ]
for you have like the Ned Stark statue
and all the other start out socks we
feel like the but we don't kind of have
the a stark vibe to them so one of the
messed up in Kunduz and the scene is
kind of like scenes where Jon Snow or
Arya or something wrong in the tunnel
reflecting and looking at you know that
just no Komodo also the Celtics are
other stars and also the overall ignore
the rules our seconds greatest weapon
and some cool stash in the background
there we go it's the Big O back there
comfortable there's the chemical Jabbar
cinder then ray our company will fight
under George Karl I spent years on the
brink of conquer in the east together
but they never did things grew toxic
five years later ray was fine chose
Jason Terry here I think because he was
like he's an old wise player at the time
and inside Jordan was elsewhere wasn't
former Tony does Jason killing but I was
under the Red Rooster that he became a
champion
don't forget about stiff carry Mike ah
surely I used quite comfortable with
Mark Jackson
but Steve Carrell easily I went down
here
I don't want our place around carelessly
got a pretty cool cape you guys wanna
come check this out
love is a candle what is this place
spelunking candles must be boring margin
yeah I don't recommend doing that in
real life you don't do not move your
head the light you'll get to not worth
these if he has giant so this is like
one of my favorite scenes of all time
and gamma zones because we had a show
Bible we wrote
beginning of season four with all the
history and everything about our
universe no root and we put in like the
white people the forest and all the
stuff were talking about and we didn't
know how to get into the show and then
there was the scene and Game of Thrones
where they're in a cave with the
dragonglass they just to go for all that
ancient cave paintings and that was like
this Eureka moment we're like yes oh
that's all I'll do it so this this
episode just takes a complete right turn
this drawing
oh yeah that must be much denied you
Smith Wow legend has it he settled
boleros and made our home especially the
flora the third was a hard and more here
yeah yeah look it says he thou maker
that's in justice Todd saw Mather trust
me this all makes you see this was a
good
[Music]
also if you pause it right here there's
a skeleton under there if you go back
like a bunch of frames sorry I forgot
about this keep keep going
oh dude be hard to find like one frame
yeah well you guys can wear this you'll
see it watch for the skeleton as we go
up here frame by frame so and there's a
skeleton
do you know the best sort of scale think
like a joke on that no wait I thought
there was like someone was very there's
some there's something about the court
being haunted
Kairi thought the court was like
something I don't know yeah wait keep
moving forward I think this Evan no does
ever know this an Evan fun fact wait
wait I forget there's something where
Kyrie thought the court was Hugo
something with the court the old he
thought the old court was haunted or
yoga no this is it the floorboards right
because they they brought back the old
court at one point and Kyrie thought it
was different he thought it was
different or something here at all they
did was repaint it this is it that's the
trophy yeah no this is the secret room
we passed by right week tweet yeah wait
okay that could cause Thurid yeah yes
that's what it was there's a big plate
or something all right so I didn't want
to penalize to everyone for wasting your
time with that and mostly I want
apologize everyone in the control room
who had to meticulously go back and
forth so that we could show you a
generic skeleton and wood so let's let's
control it
there's a sexy thon maker so thought
Makar tweeted this out afterwards he was
really excited out this episode I think
it's because we drew him like really
Jack there he is he's James Naismith
applause jump into some cues let's jump
into some cues let's see KDP says any
chance of ever releasing the our Jordan
wizard saga even through a book or story
oh the very limited chance but we did if
we did Adam if we did like a reverse
george RR martin we're like we make the
show first and then we write the novels
the gasps those novels just yeah guys so
actually the reason you're stopping the
cartoons is because Craig and I are
gonna take a few years to write these
into novels and so even if you don't see
your favorite team in a five minute
video you'll get to read about them soon
in a thousand-page novel so yeah feel
free no order the answer another
question do you want to tell talk about
the Jason Kidd freezing time I did
remember that his giant master plan
there's a giant guy of soda
this is blow we're good they're seeing
where Jason Kidd wanted to freeze time
forever and he has a giant vat of mead
and he screams from the top of Milwaukee
that he's gonna create the biggest time
out the realm has ever seen and then
spills yeah that I made and all of time
freezes then that never happened but we
ended up doing the Celtic scene where
they have soda that comes later hey
signal yeah but we did touching a little
bit but uh but yeah that was fun I
forgot about that actually um is there
anyone do one okay one more question
which is big baller says why does Yanis
run weird and the answer is because
we're a very complicated animation style
and and because we overly designed these
characters to be so realistic it's
really hard to make them run okay
and right and plus a 2d animation yeah
most cartoons are really simple like if
you look at like the design of a
spongebob like he's just like a square
with a circle eyes we are idiots and
made art style photorealistic and then
we had to move all those parts around
and that's not easy to do so that's why
sometimes it looks a little weird that's
yeah short answer alright let's write
the raid on tables castle which is a big
or maybe one of our most epic episodes
until this season premieres Thursday new
this is a great episode in my opinion I
we were to say about our own stuff but
come on this is a great episode let's
play if you like Joe was an adventure
Lord Commander
ok he was attacked at the end of the
fourth quarter for the Jester all the
rivers boy laughed you know this is such
a good episode I'm going to go to the
bathroom real quick and let Craig handle
this way on his own for two minutes
sometimes be ready sir
you know the guys I'm gonna tell you
everything we need to know about Adam
now house Clippers share their castle
with house Lakers which means W bought
five walls they were then reinforced to
protect Kobe from Shaq after his head
south and then re reinforce the protect
Kobe white and then re reread for
moving from trying to unretire I have
nothing won't be cavalier army James
Clint Trevor
Eric Ryan so here if there's someone of
Aaron and Ryan you what's your name
we never actually show the face
lieutenant is there in no Trixie who's
katadyn anymore that country's
wheelchair ramp built for support Pierce
synchronize your sundial if you time it
right we can slice through their lazy
zone defense at the rear gates black
[ __ ] exactly but we'll need a
distraction that's what you so this
scene is loosely based on oh my god
thanks for covering small window that
leads the dead man of the year and he is
behind the scenes
he's feed miss questions he's doing all
sorts of eating a grave please won't
health rockets Fanning us with giant
listen I know that you guys get annoyed
we don't really want a lot of you
welcome
but I just want you guys to know that I
feel so much more wrong than then I did
two minutes ago so thank you guys for
bearing right now I'm ready to dig it
real fun facts I'm gonna hang out here
yeah please do anything you want to
chime in like that you've been like
dying to say
you know just shut up almonds I'll get
stands in the tank was became a question
drop in Arizona
he's coming back yeah we're here because
it's what I do
Oh condors even consider fire whoa why
are you sad no I'm gonna say this thing
here which is not uh what we imply here
you want to tell them Craig what we're
implying here that there is a little bit
of a love affair here between these two
mascots we didn't identify yeah Condor
Pierre the Pelican a little Loras Tyrell
renly thing going on that we were
insinuating but it's kind of you know
hard to know what make clear no they're
supposed to do so here's Kobe shrine
James Chucky's closet
nothing and obviously this is a
different time so we were ribbing Kobe
wood in the background your three posit
presenting go back to the previous shot
we have on the wall behind trevor ariza
right there the gifts from Kobe's purple
retirement episode are in his shrine now
on the back there so you've got the
bobblehead of Michael Jordan you've got
the teddy bear that Dwight gave him
there's the wine jug which is behind
Trevor breezes head and then there is
the Kobe wine goal you know 24th goal of
the donkey that Shaq gave him so yeah
there's some tiny cut easter eggs right
there also before we pick up where we
continue I just want to say that some
comment or Stephen my thinks that Evan
looks like post Malone before we got
tattoos okay I'll take that postpones
baby yeah that's fine yeah no he's a
cool guy the cool guy I don't get I
might just have to get the Tran I don't
I guess the way where it's probably a
Mad Money guy Karl Malone you a caramel
on
Kramer this is the most elaborate pun
based plot device especially champion
know it's 81 Kobe's water 81 sir Jalen
the night of roses yes yes he values
individual accomplishments above all
others 8:1
[Music]
several reasons just like about to hit a
bunch of spikes
I am loves note the music hits one of my
favorite little moments of the show when
the light hits em in like that music
beautiful music is just I find that to
be countably moment let's top it all off
stash in from Jenna
yeah because major rivers left with
$10,000 there he's on the X so this
stand-up that Blake ledges a casting he
performs in the next episode but he ever
gets through the joke is based on actual
stand-up that Blake Griffin has done at
the improv in Hollywood and you can
watch that stand above searchin right
it's just the story tells about strip
club he goes to it's fine it's fine he's
he's finding wonderful old command but
we like them for like and repairs Marv I
traded Detroit yeah yep stand up no then
he got cool and got beard and became
cool tough Detroit auto guy and do pubes
Detroit guy yeah give me the mask after
yeah by the way also there's no reason
why I had to give us fuse to it just a
funny joke I can do this also this
doesn't make any mess that if acting
like kook it was like it's like our
equivalent of age and of a faceless men
like in the face head of a face exact
same as beer to become oh yeah right so
you have the hardened has the magical
ability to Shakespeare to become anyone
but we haven't really talked about that
much in the show but shout out to Jack
Perkins pure hoop who did the animatic
for this episode the storyboards versus
a copy is the really hard up your
stories kill that's when I make
doing something I should have done a
long time ago there's a picture in the
locker room in the back left that is
Austin Rivers hugging his dad in from
the episode where he yeah yeah yeah
something okay folks for jumber the Isle
of Van Gundy's which is my all-time
probably favorite episode everything's
my favorite episode I've no I say about
everything but I'm gonna questions for
everyone in Champions that means really
does work for us all right and so let's
answer some question ace okay nice badge
thank you I've been doing duolingo okay
someone says why does Paul Pierce need a
wheelchair ramp at the Staples Castle
great question so that's actually
because of the meme or that wasn't me it
was a one game where he left in a
wheelchair apparently because he like
pooped his pants or something I don't
exactly it was I think he might have
well rumor has it been our didn't know
that yeah but but I think what happened
was he was in a wheelchair he's wheeled
off into the locker room and wheeled
back and it turned out I believe he
sharted but don't not understand sure
about that so but something along those
lines another question
let's see miami sports fan says what
happens when a house relocates that's a
great question
and well you can see if we were gonna
get later to the 1k episode where they
have some seattle relics but you know it
kind of that area decays and becomes
like Valyria you know for the most part
they pick up the the soldiers leave and
then it becomes a ruined City yeah it's
um do we have like there's extinct
houses in Game of Thrones and there's
the
equivalent in game of zones and so like
Seattle there's also exiled houses in
Game of Thrones
and those are houses that move to
different cities so like Seattle will be
an exiled house and they sort of become
like Harrenhal which is just like this
abandoned destroyed city that is like
rumored to be haunted but yeah so campus
left-hand canvas left-hand says how do
you tell who has a deep voice like for
instance Jason Terry Oh dream on green
so a couple aspects on answer so how do
we tell there's certain guys were just
gritty players and they sort of get the
gritty air voices you know to me so
players who are tough guys players who
are bad boys that's all thing guys who
get fouls we give them the rougher sort
of Kaka need solve ever more more tough
and gritty voices and then some of the
finesse players like Steph Curry get
more voices like this and they get to
roll their arse and do things like this
you know and you know and they get a
fancy voice so it's that's generally how
we how we break it up and generally also
speaking I do some of the gritty and
lower voices and voices anyway thank you
so we're about to get jump into jump
into the van gundy island which is an
idea that Craig and I thought of like
years before we did it we were just
kicking around ideas early in gamers
owns time and time it was the summer
before this season came out we were
hanging out by the pool and we were
thinking about you know the Van Gundy's
on a tropical island and were just like
whoa like they or they could be like
monks and we were thinking about there's
this like group of monks that we had
seen like unlike at 60 minutes awhile
ago that was like they live in like a in
a church an old Greek Orthodox Church
and like a random island in the middle
of like the Mediterranean and it's like
that's the least what I was thinking of
when we had designed this episode yeah I
don't know but we having him do like
chants we thought was just funny and
then we thought about
gundy and rants so anyway we're gonna
jump in the episode now and just so you
know this episode was supposed to just
be about him training Sanjaya takes the
Pistons there to train but it turns out
then Blake Griffin got traded and we had
to implement that into the episode so
let's rock and Van Gundy and roll
they have on say like be on set my home
island grows near when we get there my
brothers will bus to in each of you
great knowledge hopefully turn this
season around I don't see anything
before you see them you'll hear them so
you might have heard this on loop before
the show started so we wrote the lyrics
first for this and then we found a like
royalty free tract Indian random
basically sang overtaking of with the
lyrics kind of safer with you and then
oh no I don't know what hey no let me
explain so used to ever it and then I
chose my favorite melody and then after
you left I did like 20 different right
harmonies over your core melody and so
it's one atom like seed voice and then
like 10 15 Craig's is the mango juice
so I want to talk about these heads for
a second these heads are all different
mashups of Stan and they're all mashups
of Stan Van and Jeff Van Gundy and all
their parts just rearranged in different
ways of different haircuts so every head
is a mash-up of Stan and death some yeah
it's like it's like stickers nose Jess
eyebrows you know like oh yeah I wanted
to pause it here you can see in the
background teeth in the top of the cave
there inside the mouth of the giant Van
Gundy head right now so that's a little
background detail that our background
artist Richard and Tom put in there
which I thought was just an awesome
textures that you can see that they're
there on the tongue in a giant van gundy
had a lot of Van Gundy shaped objects on
this island and as we go along in our
journey through Van Gundy Island I'll be
sure to point some of them out any way
we can we're taking a van through the
gun knees
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
haha brother Stan brother Joe the hell
are you this is where you can see Bo
bond is a true giant in our universe
Gordian monks will always help of course
you need Knights of Detroit come here in
form of wall I want you to meet my
brothers this is Jeff Van Gundy hello
there that's Ethan Van Gundy pleasure to
meet you RIF Van Gundy Jaron Gandhi me
are you nice here but we had considered
our sister and my girl parts yeah karma
Z no our sister and my wife Shira who I
need a wee-wee
here's another Van Gundy head that I
think no one caught because we did a
really bad job of like conveying into
the head here it's like really subtle we
tried to form a Van Gundy face out of
birds flying in front of the Sun and
then two clouds form the like balding
like the male pattern the horse you guys
[ __ ] you hair
yeah divorced your hair it's not there
really that clear but uh you know there
you go so thank you no keep going thank
you this is where we have the sweaty
Patrick Ewing statue in the background
which is one of my favorite Easter eggs
of all time just bubbles water from the
top of the Patrick Ewing people want to
know maybe why we chose Tobias Harris to
be in love have a little fling with Jan
van and after there's no reason we just
he's a well-known player he was on the
Pistons we needed someone to fall in
love with Janet van so you know he did
the bill
tomorrow I juice a screw it sander even
classic bad shooting
now this is a this is based on bombers
famous developers fellow purse
developers developers developers check
it out at Google Adam yeah you gotta
check that out it's really sweaty check
out the details on Jerry West neck that
thing little Jerry West head should be
hanging in the Louvre nice right there
I love the poses of the guys in the
background bomber just like crunch like
hunched over and is basically Jerry West
just being like a doing it's like Jedi
Mind Tricks stand back yeah we wonder
portray Jerry West is just like this
incredible psychological warrior just
he's the best at what he does and Jeff
Van Gundy just or Stan Van Gundy just
has no chance yeah oh so here's the
stand of a funny
thanks for coming out everyone so my
squad year some of the older blokes take
me to a whorehouse
that one not that one right um so a ref
walks into bar and then a table and then
some chairs
beautiful what a incredible story arc
save the cat 101 everyone this is how
you write a full on authority
perfectly wrapped up I love Gundy Van
Gundy we're gonna make a shirt I've got
a bad gun dude they're gonna round to it
yeah it severely Gandhi that was all
like Alexa cool like heels and butt
heads and then the yeah this is a
reference to when the heat and the
Knicks in the late 90s I think it was
during the playoffs we got it you'd
fight the brawl and if you search on
YouTube Jeff Van Gundy grabbed on to
Alonzo Mourning flag and you drag them
across the court so naturally what
follows is that that is how all the Van
Gundy's would exit a room so all right
want to do some questions before we tee
up the old porzingis episode okay
yeah-oh before we about that let's talk
Adam let's talk about the fact that
halfway through making that episode the
Blake Griffin trade happened and we had
to comply so it was completely yeah we
had overhauled so I touched on it for a
second in the episode but like the
details of that were that it was really
just about they were gonna go to stand
ban was having proud of their won't
they're in the AC nine seed and he's
like I'm gonna take them to the island
and hopefully my brothers can straighten
out this team and get him to be better
but then the trade happened and we had
to like figure that out and so he that's
whole second half of that was was added
on to that but that we had time to do
that because that happened around the
trade deadline this episode didn't come
out until I think April or May so so we
had a little time to take care of that
so Evan Kirby says my grandpa went to
college with Jerry West so I just want
to say - Evan Kirby very cool mg e5 says
has being the creative game as Owens
ever gotten you laid well funny story
about that no to that first question but
my girlfriend was getting ice cream and
she was wearing a game of zone shirt and
the guy upgraded her ice cream from a
small to a medium that's the only
I'm game of zones has ever benefited
someone I know and I get laid all the
time because the game is owned whenever
I do stand Ben's voice like this
whenever a house I know buddy come here
come here and get my light now
then she usually comes over and then my
wife and I have coitus so that happens
all the time
so yeah the only way I get wait actually
is when I do is dad and Ben's voice so a
great question and thanks for asking
so someone asks are you going to make
any retro NBA episodes maybe maybe not
but uh Thursday at noon you have new
season starts in those questions will be
answered what we're gonna do
let's see let's see here
where we got someone says I still don't
you uni uni quo sprit a unique Osprey
died for nine says I still don't get the
whole hunting for fouls reference can
you Spain it so the reason is because he
hunting for fouls is James Harden part
of his game is that he draws fouls he
gets people to get out he hunts for
fallacy that does tricks to get fouled
and so hunting for fouls which is a word
for certain kinds of birds was the pun
there like he was hunting fouls but in
the game he hunts for fouls
hmm pretty clever huh someone a white
chocolate asked what is your favorite
song from game of zones oh man I think
it's probably my favorite probably Lil
Wayne's purple retirement song I just I
just think everything about that is just
perfect I love I love that one oh no
favorite song
what are some songs there is obviously
that name on the cave there's name in
the case oh yeah okay you're right great
segue because my favorite
song is sung by none other than James
Dolan in the episode you're about to
watch now which is what we would call in
the business of bottle episode because
we went crazy with the last two episodes
they were so big and over-budget and so
like over the the time like we're
supposed to write them for so we had our
production manager Chris like you've got
to give me a small episode so we're like
alright we'll give you a small episode
it's gonna and this is our small episode
this is our this is the save us get us
back on schedule
yeah there's very little movement very
few characters
kristaps are you excited about your new
Lord Commander phys Dale so we finally
next won't be getting broke 30 times
made someone old man and it's Walt
Frazier dingus is now like the fourth
brand and there's gonna be more so he
brandy and his hair was fair just like
yours but he had a third eye that could
see also a bad back I hate your stories
I know so worried about the child the
way that we wrote this episode Knicks
fan on the office in to shout-out to
Lance Becker in the VR graphics
department is nothing he's all sorts of
things I don't know now he oversees a
lot but he came in he's a Knicks fan
he's a grumpy Nick's family brought him
in we sat him down we said through the
entire reign of James Dolan Fanning's
are born and live and die or without
seeing a playoff win or a decent draft
pick it was in this darkness
that Isiah Thomas gave a five year
contract to Rome big snacks James who
exactly our intention here is to really
be like I'm part of an expanse watching
stuff on Bobby just want to let it all
out and like it's the perfect metaphor
was talking up a long night but in
context of salvation it's also very
satisfying for me as to we gonna do this
we're gonna do this about the Sixers
Adam this is gonna be a sixer scene
about the process yeah yeah it was like
market Holt's or someone playing a bit
yeah yeah I decided my workers we were
20 and hear this song JD in a straight
shot stolen just better find a church
better find ourselves a good place to
cry cuz we're not going to tank or play
Frank nil aquinnah who's moody is a guy
betta find acept
a good place word on the street
a little birdie is that James in love
this episode shout-out to designers did
a christop space to play over the
credits that we're playing I think
Alfred Payton is the next Bradley feel
all right Kris lab spores [ __ ] time
for you to hurry up and heal a little
birdie told me Fitz is European big man
see in Lithuania deposits so there's
actually some interesting unused lower
that we I don't think we'll ever use
because I think we erased it from the
show Bible but we had an idea that
unicorn players would actually grow
unicorn horns out of their forehead
remember that Adam we designed a unicorn
version of Chris stops that and and yeah
he originally not a mourner comes up
yeah there was there are certain very
special players in the league who could
grow horns and this was like a sign
they're part of an ancient very special
magical collection of players known as
unicorn players to try and they would
try to hide their horns because there
was like a purging of unicorns at one
point and so they like to shave it down
and like LeBron had one and that was
like explained his like hair surgery it
was actually like a a horn surgery and
then like Yanis had one but he had like
buck antlers and it was a whole thing
but we never really got into it alright
so we're going to do a few
quick questions here because somehow we
are we were going slowly here it's it's
9:00 p.m. and we're not even hit like we
just get done episode 6 was that so
we're gonna roll let's see we've got a
couple someone said what was someone
says I bet James our chavacano says I
bet James Dolan has banned you guys from
the garden that would be an honor
I would I would love to be amongst the
yeah if he if he could recognize us
maybe he would but here's an interesting
question from Christopher choices what
was what do you think was the most
disappointing episode Craig do you have
a most disappointing episode I don't
know how was it episode of disappointing
cuz like we're making it like I can I
can give an answer I can give an answer
and actually tell them I have an idea -
yeah okay you want to go yeah I would
say just I was disappointed that the Sun
Kings didn't get as positive a response
as I thought it deserved I was really
excited about that episode and people
just didn't want to see an episode with
like bad teams in it but I personally
love episodes about bad teams I think
they're really like it's just a funny
area to write about and yeah everyone
talks about the games yeah
is it's things that people want to just
see good players they don't necessarily
want to see like the funniest players
sometimes but yeah whatever
and I would say actually for me
I thought the Celtics episode of the
next season episode 7 where the one
we're lucky dies was I thought was so
funny that like he talks for 2 minutes
about lucky dying but apparently that
episode was not that what it seems like
people now like it but but back then it
like people really thought it was a
disappointing episode and I was
disappointed by the reaction because I
personally thought the like long
explanation of like how he died I
thought that whole episode really clever
and so I'd say that how that was people
reacted that was probably the for me was
slightly disappointing but now people
seem to like and generally people like
it overall anyway so we're now gonna
jump into the next episode which is a
doozy
one of the
most popular episodes in one of my
favorite episodes MBA 1k
[Music]
here we are at the pick and roll in oh
yeah we wanted to pause it here well
yeah it's like oh and I'm like oh yeah
we said posit here so in the
pick-and-roll in is basically a bar that
or a in that has a like a tavern Allen
that's run by squash the mascot of the
the Seattle SuperSonics because he's out
of a job so he opened them and in and
it's based on the in that hot pie was in
in Game of Thrones and he decorated the
whole interior with old memorabilia
memorabilia from Celtic that the Celtics
the SuperSonics and the Sonics I keep
saying SuperSonics but um it's just
where people go to hang out they meet
with other team members and you can see
on the wall we have a painting of the
Rain Man Shawn Kemp and then we have
also a portrait way in the back that is
the inside the NBA guys or as we call
them inside the realm and you'll see it
a little bit closer later on in the
episode but we actually gave that
portrait to Ernie Johnson and Shaq and
Charles and Kenny when we were on inside
the NBA a couple years back and now
Ernie Johnson has that porch that
painting behind him in all of his videos
from quarantine where he's like live
streaming and like interviewing people
so that's a weird little connection that
we weren't expecting to happen
so anyway is there anything else from
this shot Adam that you wanted to point
out no I think we're you think you
covered it all let's let's roll the clip
come on Ben take a free pointer what are
you afraid of oh right the fact that it
definitely won't go in this guy talks
more trash than a young Kobe it also
takes more bird shots than the old one
least I take shots Benny one point
alright just roll some of us actually
have real games to play I'll take the
part of the troika Lloyd Celtics had
just been the Sixers in the playoff
that's a turnover who mistakes like that
can cost you squirrely
but I guess you can always try again
next so whose turn is it Adam and I are
default UK players like their people the
office yeah at least report for a huge
UK players meet Sri Francis and the
Shawn Mishra how is it and we just
grilled them I have all the complaints
about can I see Molly and we made fun of
it let me find in this cartoon the the
Mona Lisa joke was actually a joke that
someone made on reddit and it was such a
good joke that like we just wanted to do
a proper painting of it and then we gave
the person credit in the end we asked
the permission but I was too good of a
joke than not it's actually pretty solid
he looks like modeling this is really
fun to draw him as the Mona Lisa doesn't
look anything like me
I guess they are lazy fools the work of
the drift what's my rights you can see
Jason Kidd and squash because I just got
fired both have been fired at this point
probably change so the drink another
star is awakened why don't you just
create your own night huh I suppose I
should oh one of those those are your
default 1k boots you start with them now
hey little me can't be seen in these
because you got a car of your own player
character from this version of the game
but I warn you again civ what 500 covers
for boots that's madness well you can't
put a price on the old the old me big
baller brand robots there that was today
you brony one other of you kids remember
that bat need a bigger brand overcharge
for sandals you try you boy come on
well then I'd like your eyes just Rock
UK for Mike
I'll trade us Ronnie 1k he's like the
face of NBA 2k nothing changed his
avatar to this weird was absolutely man
creating a paper of add many encompasses
reading his at mentions office are you
right so but yeah virtual currency was a
very big frustration for people you have
to bought use real money to buy fake
money and then use that fake money to
see you get perks in the games and it
drove people crazy I think what do I do
no dad wait
best my kill you ready no okay I'll send
a full court pass to Mitchell
all right roll for it the older miss
Lanza's got weird shooting for him now
I've picked up all 100 of my virtual if
you're wondering we don't have the game
we have put some thought into it
sort of like Dungeons & Dragons you're
free sure so after the battle you run
into Matt Barnes he asks you if you'd
like to join him on a 95 mile quest to
kick derek Fisher's ass this is loose
this artwork is loosely based on Sophie
butts the tapestry Bayou tapestry boring
can we skip which is one of them look it
was a it's a thousand-year-old knee op
demigod alpha this range y'all a
barbecue chicken damn cool and it only
cost me twenty thousand coppers and
three me goats or our twos get in pulse
the game is almost over
you sure you don't want to stop in okay
I'm ready has he put up Jimbo top of the
key bump heads with like this shoulder
than being holidays over Benjamin's not
good also the boot to love them driven
hot right you can see the shields in the
background of like house cannonballs is
a reference to the bullets which is
another it's all these old retired teams
and teams exist anymore wanted to honor
them pull up a stunt like that by the
way shout out some at Hill these first
season with a writer arriving so bit
more the time that uptight gets here may
I just meant great reasonably new II
wonder works for some consideration well
if either of your houses were in the
West you wouldn't even be considered for
Squire of the year stop your squabbling
children some Squire of the year orders
only know that the Jason Kidd is I'm not
and who the hell are you
Malcolm Brogdon has an old man voice
because he's a second year okay let's in
here let's answer a couple questions
here oh but I was I got a scroll down
here let's see we explained the shield's
what about uh I'm not gonna answer that
because it would contain spoilers so
I'll give that Greg beautiful I can't
find a gate oh I
I'm ready tired or confusing to me
someone says Brett David see just wants
to let everyone know they thinks Bradley
bills underappreciated when sure Evan
Matthews likes cuz he's a Wizards fan
and then we have the questions towards
wizard related ones yeah someone asked
why does Walt Frazier speak in rhyme and
the reason is if you you should check
out he does he's an announcer for the
the Knicks and he's also a former player
if you you don't know that and uh and he
just says classic things like he's in
that commercial
he always rhymes things it's the way he
speaks and that's that's one of his
things he's known for like if there's a
there's a just for man commercial ways
like the beard is weird and he's talking
about like Emmitt Smith's beard or
something like that and then someone
else asks let me see yeah Joshua Conniff
says I know that's that's the old one
about James Olney build someone asks why
I can't find the question but someone
saying why is there when playing lute
and the reason is because he actually
plays in a band called JD in the
straight shot and I should check them
out check them out uh on the Internet
what if you dare Scott you want to do it
on Craig yeah I can't pronounce this
because it's got numbers instead of
letters at the Shogun
yeah Shogun but with a five for an S and
a six Virgie do you guys get hate mail
from players we actually don't get hate
mail so far we've only heard good things
from players oddly enough they don't
really seem to get offended they they
seem to really like their the episodes
the only one as we mentioned before is
TJ Warren
might have sub tweeted us because right
after that Sun Kings episode came out he
had some like generic tweet that just
happened to come out right after that
was just like you got to ignore the
haters and all this stuff and so it's in
the back of our minds that it might have
been related but can't confirm
so we'll just assume that he enjoyed the
episode but why don't we uh why don't we
show the last word of this season
well last one one quick question I'll
say Scott Novak says is Ronny 1k based
on anyone yes he's based on Ronnie 2k
who is a 2 K face of 2 K guy anyway
let's let's do it so this episode
features our fastest scene we've ever
made to be topical yeah this episode
should know he did not go to the Lakers
but look but where will you go also Adam
really wanted to get anything about
grunions don't explain with grunions are
you're wearing it like this yeah there's
a little fish that swim up on the beach
at a certain time mostly like the eggs
are coming in in Los Angeles people
sometimes in the West Coast like they go
and see the grunion lay their eggs the
most very Hollywood you only know it if
you live in LA so we don't know it you
don't know this episode is for scenes in
it and we basically made them in order
of most topical so we could keep
updating them as the playoffs played out
so we make this episode go and during
the playoffs it's the most stressful
episode to make so we're gonna make this
scene first because we knew that Toronto
got out early in the tournament notice
the orange slices on the table there
that is a reference to that's a hint
that is LeBron because and we eat orange
slices in this playoff so there's a lot
of footage of his license number one
seed and since when does old Drake give
two feasts in a single fortnight
well it's no good being a lot of the
core pervert of the owl is one of the
underrated moments in the show yeah
that's that's a top ten show also I love
the mascots obviously before the
wrestlers won yes
this seat is based on Walder Frey
actually when a big spoiler so if you
haven't seen Game of Thrones again brah
I'm sorry about a spoiler for your re-of
us as well defray us what the scene is
based on yeah he has his wife he has a
lot of like watch Walder Frey and that's
the horse is basically Drake's like
equivalent Norman Powell flapping so
hard
proper wine so proper night's champagne
[Music]
it was just such a perfect mashup with
the rapper's choking not wasting go to
the scene where they all choke to death
it was just so it was like it was like
the writers George our barn just gifted
us the scenes to do it for the Raptors
Knicks game
also notice how LeBron saves the horse
here she wants the force to send a
message but also I think it's a little
message that we're sending that LeBron
has a heart and he's not willing to
heard horses horse things yeah he's yeah
exactly
haven't you
so there's clipping his fingernail
there's another thing he did famously on
the sideline that seriously no we're
just joking
you get used to it this is a sick burn
but the boy did they show us the next
season huh
so LeBron rips off a the Alice or
Verburg tell them King James to rules
the east also tell them I'm better than
Michael Joey oh boy this sets off in
motion some things but you'll have to
find out Thursday at noon when episode
one premieres of the new season
yeah you got okay this is this is okay
I'm just pausing it for one second if
you can I just want to quickly mention
something about the scene so this scene
was this the whole burger thing happened
with Bryan Colangelo and everyone in
Philly was like you guys are Sixers fans
you have to do something for this and
Craig and I were like on the phone like
remember like 1:00 a.m. that night well
who gotta think of something we've got
to do something but the problem is it's
the it's very hard to deal with what we
call like an evolving hot story it's
like lava that hasn't settled yet and
it's very tricky to write something
before you know how people are gonna
react how the story's gonna have fallout
and stuff like that and when his burner
story came out it was very unclear as a
big mystery and it was it was it was
evolving and it turned out it was why
isn't that but we knew we had to do
something with it so we sum this we
threw this thing together it's the same
backgrounds that we used for the process
scene we already had his head build we
just beefed up his collar we'd used it
for the new sentence yeah so yeah that
was the key to this was that we were
able to reuse all these resources okay
really fast
everything was designed it was very
strategically set up and then
comfortable soon after the main new
design was the giant collars all these
Ravens are saying all suites
that his burner accounts I said in real
life oh thank you honest this is such a
specific story that like it's like
barely remember you know my wife decided
so I like the hoagie scenes that is that
might out there Philly reference yeah
that love you all
really yeah you guys might knew it ahead
you from Philadelphia one two three four
five six seven
did someone mention me this is the
actual burner handles no dinky is better
and smarter than you Eric jr. that's an
actual do we bed the process this is
case of Brian long collars feel bad
about we are just like we're rubbing it
in right as being five analytics was it
no
so he blames him I love Leslie all right
and I really disagreed with Adam I did
not want to do this scene just put that
out there but you know I thought this is
a great idea it's still a cool scene
it's just that calling them the Spurs of
the East was yeah it's working I agree
I stayed screw with the lore great great
background our there's a bulldog oh yeah
what are you doing I think it's a great
scene I just don't like screwing with
the lore yeah we screwed up I don't know
the soul box gets like very confusing
[Music]
like this does yeah there is the very
first men daughter the the mrs. Adams
the report on how yeah that slipper is
tied to this whole block magic
and we get into a little bit later
episodes and that was the end of that
season so take a quick question then
we're gonna jump into our bonus unaired
scene that you're gonna see so sorry to
show that so I got an answer Anthony's
question here okay
Anthony's saying please take this
question Adam he says will the Celtics
mascot ever come back to life
and so here's well says he in real life
he never died
he's still here he's with us forever
he's always and in our world he's always
in our hearts and he'll always be bones
and whenever we're missing lucky we can
go back and we can watch that episode
and we can remember that he died a hero
providing entertainment for old Brad
Stevens
so will you boy I don't know anything's
possible it's all this world is a
simulator you get anything's possible
Adam believes the universe is a
simulation just casually putting that
out there
Amazon's why is Washington called
Washington fell because washing fell
it's a it's a portmanteau of Washington
and Winterfell we mashed them together
and they worked they worked nicely
together I think and I am I like that
city name in our universe few cities got
some weird names like bostonia mill of
Waukee at Mililani yeah so okay so let's
tee up this final thing where you're
about to see so what you're about to see
and Craig you might have to explain what
a thematic is after this probably give a
quick explanation of what was the
backstory is here if this was a scene
that we had ready had the Celtics that
year when Kyrie got injured and they
made that whole run had the Celtics
beaten the Cavs and had they gone to the
finals against the Warriors or the wars
were playing the Rockets and that was
actually quite a precarious that was a
that was that game 720
seven threes in a row thing so that was
there was a lot of risk here I think
that was yeah that was that season but
had it been Warriors and Celtics in the
finals we we would have done this scene
in the final episode and this is a
parody of Braveheart and this is but we
never took it to animation it only got
as far as thematic so oh actually this
is a chatot ed animatic yeah this is
this is it because an animatic although
it's kind of in-between but it's a
storyboard that is put to the audio that
we had already made so we make the audio
first and then we draw the artwork and
we do the editing in a storyboard phase
so that we don't have to edit the way
that life like television man Jim bees
are yeah wait what are you
live-action there way hold on anyway
okay well I've actually I've done all
right like yeah thanks okay so
live-action they'll shoot a lot of
footage then they'll edited afterwards
for us we have to plan it out ahead of
time so anyway that's what this is and
let's just let's just roll the tape
let's show them the we're gonna be quiet
because we promised some guy in the
beginning we're gonna be quiet
yeah go dicks
it's been a hell of a run but I'm afraid
this is where it ends after all the wise
men say our Midland house should be
proud just append the needs of the great
golden dynasty but I ask you my brothers
are these not the same wise men who
declared us dead when Sir Haywood lost
his foot for Kyrie his knee well it
seems the only dead man being buried
today are the ones who stood in our way
now I know some of you tremble at the
sight of that golden army up on those
hills but I can assure you they are just
as scared of us
ready the scary men directly after the
parade there will be a pool party at
Steph's castle do not fill up on hors
d'oeuvres
where are you sure we'll be preparing
her famous citrus shrimp salad with
Dijon lace vinaigrette you know I get it
on the side we will play all position
through we will each mark all men right
we will switch and switch and when they
adjust
we will switch again they may have more
talent or battle my wife looked me in
the eyes and she told me to ask all of
you one question do any of you have any
dietary restrictions thirst are you
figured we are the men who cut down the
freak who crushed the process and then
went and slayed the king name of William
Russell Larry the Bird and the knight of
truth let us restore the glory of
bostonia
ooh gags oh they they could take our
names but they can't take our position
let freedom
[Applause]
that's it
so that was that would often Fang asked
which scene will dis replace and I guess
it would have replaced probably
definitely the pop scene at the end
where they put the clipboard in Brad
Stevens it would probably been yeah
friend we wouldn't have that same this
before so yeah this scene we barely can
do a scene about the files but we were
so confident that the Warriors were
gonna beat the Celtics that year if the
Celtics had gone through that we were we
were just gonna predict that and hope
that yeah but I loved that scene I think
it's a great scene Craig found that
today and I hadn't seen in a long time
so it's good but anyway guys it's that
time its 9:27 and that's when we have to
say goodbye so I just want to say to
everyone thank you guys so much for
giving us a little bit of your time and
for being here with us fan links and I
will see you tomorrow for our last yes
way to market last flash party
[Music]
my tower is allways waffling and
complaining here look watch killer
[Music]
five millions of
suspended from the
ruins again
[Music]